biomass is a local resource we can bring
it to the local energy plant and this
way we can be self-sufficient with
energy today my name is Jen's del Benson
I'm the inventor of a new biomass
furnace
well our plant can take various types of
fuel kitchen waste garden waste
agricultural waste forest waste so we
can take whatever nature is giving us we
push in biomass into the furnace and we
add air to the bottom of the furnace and
here we produce gas which is burned in
the top part and we produce here by a
hot gas which is cooled in the boiler
producing the heat secondly we produce
even more heat in the condenser we're
taking all the moisture out of the flue
gas and we can then make about 30% extra
heat over this heat exchanger it's a
simple design simple to operate cheap to
built and we have very little emissions
that can harm the environment as one of
the main issues it burn very clean this
plant is in bones in Denmark the town of
6,000 people and the plant provides the
heat for all the town we can have high
percentage of our energy needs provided
by these plants 20-30 percent is
realistic in many countries
you